welcome to this video playing DD from
France fifteen point five out of twenty
s Moscow and maybe his opening choices
influenced by that is playing a weird
gambit okay
yeah I'm just going to develop him h5m
maybe is having a bad run something
similar to me I also had very bad very
bad recent sessions
okay well this should be punished in the
center somehow so maybe III deform you
know yeah my idea is that after this I
will have I will have a pretty quick
play against the skin with with Bishop
f4 especially opieop III first not clear
maybe start with this and then rooks e1
Jana rooks e1 he cannot play king b8
because of Bishop f4 that's it's already
a big problem
check I can take p7 but it's this the
best way to blame I'm sure before is
Queenie foreheads
but easiest is the check probably check
takes takes Queen b7 I can exchange the
Queen's I don't really want to treat
right anymore there should be a maid
maid happening jealousy image I really
don't maybe we should Bishop f4 first
maybe this first queen Queenie father's
rupee three I can afflict this in this a
good idea
Andrew P 3 is the next movie Alice this
was this is the reputation I think Queen
Queen b7 now takes and queen b7 or
before clicking this n is probably a
good idea would like to play Queen b6
Queen b7 ever this is a checker check on
on on the Queen on the king check
probably missing Donna Windsor it really
feels like that
and I should have taken your first now
Kim it's um it's still a very good
endgame check of course that's far less
than what I what I should have gotten
good thing is that the time missus okay
don't have a time issue
what's the easiest gym I'm going to
check kick him
I get get the edge porn anyway check
check-check
check check check okay this is a winning
setup now I can go to a g5 check black
Brazilian yeah it was a very bad way to
realize this advantage I mean what did i
do there it's probably made somewhere
this there really should be Jennings
plus 11 I couldn't I couldn't find it so
Bishop c7 of course Bishop d7 ah okay
okay
rookie three is the next win this is
check no I really should take b7 the
terrible thing is jester this is still a
winning endgame it's just just bad
technical play before I just need to
finish him off earlier but this is
really a winning routine game he's he's
a pawn down and all pawns a week this is
a bit too much
chanty I'm always getting the h5 pawn
yeah okay he probably I don't know this
was like a bit of an on tilt game maybe
yet a bad run we can we can check this
he lost the last last three games so
it's this was a fourth fourth game of
the session and he lost the first three
one I know the feeling it's just just
happens okay well thanks for watching